yeah and actually yeah you would like to  put both of your pieces yeah on the  night and the Bishops that would be the  best Square for Knight and the bishop  but you can only put one and this brings  the end game uh-huh Bishop Bishop B4  F32 it's coming yeah I mean all these  Knight a Tuesday night on E6 has to stay  there because Bishop C7 is otherwise  always a very big threat if the Knight  moves from A6 but anyway it's not going  very far actually yeah and I teach what  Magnus blunder the bishop  oh my God  exactly at the moment when he was uh  starting to to stay he was doing so uh  such a blunder by Magnus Carlsen hanging  a bishop  well honestly I I when I first mentioned  Bishop C7 I also blundered it and I  quickly corrected that while the Knight  on E6 you shouldn't be playing this oh  my God yeah  because he